- [Instructor] We talked
about the dissemination
of information being
a force of convergence
on the global scale.
But what about on the individual scale?
When we're talking about
knowledge dissemination
on an individual scale,
we're really talking about
education on some level.
So once again, this is a
topic very close to my heart.
So let's just go through a
few thought experiments here.
So in general, you have income.
Income, and that income,
in order to produce it, you need capital.
You need capital.
And you need,
you need labor.
For example, if you're running a farm,
you need land and you need animals
and you need some equipment,
but you also need people to
run the equipment and manage the farm.
If you're running a software company,
you need a building, you need computers,
you need servers.
I guess that's computers as well.
But you need people to
program the computers
and to sell the software
and to develop it and whatever else.
So these are the two things that you need
in order to produce output,
which you would recognize
in terms of income.
But then the question is how
does that income get split?
How much of it goes to the capital,
and how much goes to labor?
And the idea here is, is that
if you have dissemination
of knowledge and if knowledge work
becomes more and more and more valuable,
so if knowledge work,
so let me put a little,
little aura around this.
So this is the aura of knowledge.
If this is knowledge work
and it's less and less of a commodity,
then maybe labor has more leverage here.
On the other hand,
if you have these hugely
capital-intensive industries
where labor is kind of this
monotonous, unskilled work,
then maybe capital has
more of the leverage.
Now let's just think about,
and Piketty tends to
be a little dismissive
of this happening on a large scale.
He says it might be happening in pockets.
It might be happening
in pockets in terms of,
you know, managers in finance
or maybe in certain industries
like the software industry.
But in his mind, this isn't,
this knowledge dissemination
isn't going to make
labor important enough in
order to offset this whole,
in more and more income going to capital,
especially after
generation and generation,
potentially leading to dynastic wealth.
But the one thought
experiment, once again,
my goal here isn't to
give my point of view,
it's really to just give
you things to think about
and for you to come to
your own point of view,
is to think about the comparison
between the present day
and the Gilded Age, which the book makes.
If we look at the Gilded Age,
so let me write this here.
So the Gilded Age,
so this is the end of the
19th century, the late 1800s.
The Gilded Age,
what were the forces of
growth in the Gilded Age?
Where was a lot of the
income being generated from?
Well, this was really the peak
of the Industrial Revolution.
You have things like railroads,
railroads.
You have oil, I guess you could
say, you know, energy, oil.
You have manufacturing,
manufacturing.
All of these industries are
incredibly capital-intensive.
Capital is very important.
You can't even do these
things without capital.
And in all of these, labor
is a bit of a commodity,
that, hey, you just need
people to kind of, you know,
nail the railroad ties
in and things like that.
You need people to just,
you know, work on the rig.
You need people to work
on the assembly line.
And the Industrial Revolution
was really a process
of taking these crafts and
turning them into more and more,
you know, one-off, almost you
could call it commodity labor.
Now let's think about the present day,
and we could probably,
I think it's fair to call
it the Information Age,
Information Age.
And what are the growth industries
in the Information Age?
Well, one that's close to my heart,
I'm making this video in the
middle of Silicon Valley,
is software.
Actually, that's probably the one
that really stands out to
me as a major growth area,
but there's, you know, kind of biotech,
biotech, we could go on and on and on.
And what's common about all of these?
Well, they're not necessarily
as capital-intensive as what we see here.
In particular, if we're
talking about software,
it's not very capital-intensive at all.
You just need some computers
and a place to program,
and you can, in theory, do
it inside someone's house.
And this is really more about highly,
highly, highly skilled labor.
Same thing with biotech,
it does need capital,
but that capital isn't for railroads
or isn't for, you know, hugely,
I mean, there is some equipment,
but it's mainly for people.
It's mainly for researchers
and people to run the clinical
trials and for whatever else.
And so we are, it seems
like we are in an age
where labor is going to become
more and more invaluable,
more valuable, but not
just commodity labor,
not just to someone to kind of, you know,
work one shift at the factory,
but highly, highly, highly skilled labor.
Now, just because this is happening, this,
or because this is happening,
this could be a driver
of more and more income going to labor.
But that by itself wouldn't necessarily
drive off inequality.
For example, you might have a situation,
and there's some date signs
that maybe this is happening,
where if you look at, if
this is the pool of folks,
that the people who are
able to participate in this,
these high-growth sectors
where labor adds a
significant amount of value,
that that's actually a small
percentage of this population.
So a small percentage of the population
is going to take advantage,
could potentially take
advantage of these, and if,
of these dynamics.
But if the rest of the population
doesn't have the skills necessary,
then they're going to
essentially be left out
of this growth, and so that
could still drive inequality.
It won't be driving inequality
because of income going
more and more to capital,
because of R being greater than G,
because returns of capital
are greater than growth.
It wouldn't be because of that.
It would be because of this
differentiation in labor
where highly, highly skilled labor
is getting a disproportionate
share of the income
relative to other labor.
So the question is,
is can we get more people
to participate this?
And once again, this is
an issue of education.
Can we get this pool, as a
percentage of the population,
to become a much larger
pool of the population
so more and more,
so more and more of the world,
more and more of the world
can participate in that?
So once again, this is just
something to think about.
I don't know the answer to this,
but there are some dynamics in play.
And we're definitely in
a different type of world
than we were in the Gilded Age.
Another way that you could think about it,
and this isn't from the book,
but this is just a way that
I sometimes think about it.
If you think, in the
Industrial Revolution,
you have the world was kind of a,
the world was kind of a pyramid,
that down here you have your labor,
then, and you needed a lot of folks there,
but it was relatively unskilled.
And then in the middle,
you kind of have your white-collar jobs.
You could, white-collar jobs,
you know, this is the folks
who are kind of manipulating
information, filing papers,
et cetera, et cetera, the office jobs.
And then at the top of the pyramid
during the Industrial Revolution
and really going into the
20th century, you had,
you could, I guess you could
say your capital owners,
your owners of capital.
And then you had also a very small,
you had a very small, I
would say, creative class.
So this is creative,
creative,
creative class.
And so this would be folks like engineers
and artists and people doing research.
And so, this is essentially
the dynamic you had.
But now when we go into
the Information Age,
automation is making labor,
is making labor less important
in even white-collar jobs,
information processing.
And so there's two different realities
that we could potentially go to.
There's one where essentially
you still have a relatively small
class of people who own capital
or own most of the capital
or, and a creative class.
And then you have a small,
you have a, actually, let me just,
so if I just take that triangle,
that same triangle right over there,
so you still have a small group of people
who fall into the top of the triangle.
And because automation is
taking care of these middle two,
you only need a small sliver of people
who are participating in here.
And so everyone else here
is essentially going to be left out.
So these folks are going to be left out,
which isn't a good recipe for anyone.
But there's another reality where,
well, what if we could
expand this top triangle
where we can have a larger
and larger creative class?
And if these people can
participate in the high-value labor
jobs, I guess you can say,
then they are going to be in a position
to capture more and more of the income,
and then they will also be in a position
to have more and more capital.
You see that happening in Silicon Valley.
People who get a neat software job
at Google or Facebook or Apple,
not only, you know, they're getting that
through their labor,
but because that income is
larger than their expenses,
they're able to start
to accumulate capital
and also become capital owners.
So there's a reality that,
if we play our cards right in education,
and once again, this is close to my heart,
maybe instead of going to this world
where we leave all of these people out,
we can go to a world
that looks more like this
where we don't need a lot of labor
because of automation, more kind of,
I guess you could say commodity labor.
We don't need a lot of
kind of the traditional
white-collar jobs in
information processing.
And then most people,
if we can get education to be good enough,
can now participate in
these really high-value jobs
where labor has a lot more leverage,
where the returns to labor are larger
than the returns to capital.
And because the returns
to labor are larger,
you're going to have those people also,
they're gonna get more share of income,
and they're also going to be able to start
to accumulate capital.
So getting to this reality
where you're having a
larger and larger percentage
of people who are
essentially capital owners,
capital owners and software
engineers and artists
and people doing R and D,
in my mind, this is predicated
on improving education.
So to get from here to here
and to avoid going to this top one,
it really is about having
a more talented labor pool,
a more educated labor pool.
And if we pull this off, then we get into
what could be considered
kind of a Star Trek reality.
A Star Trek reality, people
don't really view Star Trek
from economic point of
view, but in Star Trek,
you might realize that
there aren't a lot of people
kind of tilling the fields here.
There aren't a lot of people
just kind of doing desk jobs at Star Trek.
Everyone at Star Trek
is either doing R and D,
they are Explorers,
or they are artists.
So once again, just
something to think about,
that education, that
knowledge dissemination
could be a very, very
powerful force of convergence
and keep us from going
into another Gilded Age.